Optimal, minimal at this altitude,
I can run flat out for a half mile before
my hands start shaking familiar else?
Your personal question now
with the, it's like to be,
I'm a cybernetic organism, living
tissue over metal endoskeleton.
So this episode is brought
to you by [inaudible]
headspace. More than 80% of
the people I have interviewed,
world-class performers across
the military, entertainment,
sports, and beyond all have some
type of meditative practice.
I tried for years and
years and failed miserably.
The key is making it simple and you can
dramatically improve your life in just
10 minutes a day. And
technology can help you.
This change comes through
guided meditation and
headspace is by far the most
popular app for this purpose.
More than 4 million users.
It's meditation made simple.
So what I recommend is that you
take this practice meditation,
which is rooted in thousands
of years of tradition,
supported by thousands
of scientific studies,
and try it for 10 minutes
a day for 10 days.
That's all you need to do. You
could also check out the founder,
Andy Puddicombe, uh, ted talk, which
has more than 5.5 million views.
His last name is p, U. D. D. I. C. O.
M. B. E. If you want to look that up.
But otherwise, download
the free headspace app.
I have it on my phone and begin their
take 10 program for 10 days of guided
meditation. Completely free. 10
minutes a day. That's all it takes.
You should give it a shot.
headspace.com forward slash Tim just
go to headspace.com forward slash. Tim
this episode is brought to you by 99
designs when your business needs a logo,
website, business card,
thumbnail, or any other design.
I recommend checking out 99
designs. I use them myself.
I've used them for many years.
I use them to create book cover
prototypes for the four hour body,
which went on to becoming number
one New York Times bestseller.
I've also used them for
banner ads, illustrations,
and much more with 99 designs.
You get a variety of original designs
from designers around the world.
Give your feedback and then pick your
favorite. Your happiness is guaranteed.
So check out some of my competitions and
designs and some of your competitions
in designs from fellow Tim Ferriss show
listeners@ninetyninedesigns.com forward
slash Tim and right now you can get a
free $99 upgrade on your first design,
so check it out. 99
designs.com forward slash Tim
[inaudible].
Hello boys and girls.
This is Tim Ferriss and welcome to
another episode of the Tim Ferriss show.
Where does usually my job to deconstruct
world class performers across all
different areas and industries, whether
they be military, chess, sports,
entertainment, or otherwise.
Business. Of course, the obvious one.
This time it is a conversation between
friends and I am extremely excited to
have Kevin Kelly back on the Kevin
Kelly. I've said this before,
might be the real life, most
interesting man in the world.
I'm not making up what
I'm about to read to you.
He is senior maverick at wired magazine,
which he cofounded in 1983 he also
cofounded the all Species Foundation,
a nonprofit aimed at cataloging
and identifying every
living species on earth in
his spare time. Of course, I'm
using that tongue and cheek.
He writes bestselling books, many of
them cofounded the Rosetta project,
which is building an archive
of all documented human
languages and serves on the
board of the long now
foundation as part of the last,
he's investigating how to revive and
restore endangered or extinct species,
including the wooly mammoth
that is not made up. Folks.
We touched on a lot of really fun stuff
in this episode and when Kevin arrived
at my house to record,
I had certain plans and I asked him what
he wanted to highlight or focus on and
we just decided to catch up as friends.
So this is very truly the
type of conversation that
led me in the first place
many moons ago.